98 tage krieg in der ukraine und wir
müssen uns die lage ansehen im osten des
landes und im süden des landes vier
schauen zuerst einmal die karte an dort
wo jetzt gerade die kämpfe toben nämlich
einerseits in den regionen lohans
kornetzky im osten des landes und
andererseits und das ist relativ neu
jetzt auch wieder in carson hier im
süden des landes wir schauen aber erst
noch einmal wie gesagt in den osten dort
haben wir die großstadt sie wäre das
tiefere tun es ist eine von zwei
allerletzten städten größeren städten in
der region lohans die noch unter
ukrainischer kontrolle bis gestern waren
muss man sagen denn sie wird im netz man
sieht es hier wurde gestern von
russischen truppen angegriffen und es
sieht so aus als wären zumindest die die
wohngebiete die größte der größte teil
sozusagen der stadt als wäre der
komplett eingenommen worden von
russische truppen mittlerweile unter
umständen gibt es noch kämpfe oder
ukrainische einheiten die sich in den
industriegebieten dort zurückziehen wir
sehen uns mal die videos an die jungs
aus der region netz erreichen das ist
zum einen mal hier ein video der jahr
der pseudo volksrepublik lugansk dort
sieht man wie durch die wälder östlich
der stadt die truppen sich nähern man
sieht jetzt hier wie die ersten
wohngebiete in erscheinung treten um
dann gehen die truppen die ja die pro
russischen truppen hier in dieser stadt
hinein ziemlich krasse aufnahmen man
sieht kaum jemand ist noch da jetzt sind
die karten in einer schule gucken sich
das ganze an gucken sich an was da was
da passiert ist wir hören einige
explosionen im hintergrund allerdings
keine direkten kämpfe und das ist
relativ interessant und spannend bevor
weitermachen die ukrainischen soldaten
haben hier wohl eine andere taktik
benutzt als in mario pohl sie haben sich
nicht einkesseln lassen sie haben nicht
den großen kampf gesucht sondern sie
sind tatsächlich haben sich aus der
stadt zurückgezogen hier sehen wir ein
weiteres video was uns gestern erreicht
hat das ist das wärmekraftwerk von zivil
hier dringend weitere russische truppen
vor und zwar in diesem fall sehr
spannend wagner sollte also seltener
hoch ausgebildete killer die sozusagen
für putin hier diese stadt erobern
sollen auch von den kämpfen mittlerweile
tausende manche sagen sogar zehntausende
im osten der ukraine um eben die
gefallenen russischen soldaten wir
wissen dass ein 20 bis 30 tausend
russische soldaten gestorben bereits in
diesem krieg dort zu ersetzen hier sieht
man wie sie in wohnviertel vordringen
und wie sie das ist in dem fall ganz
interessant wie sie auf diesen panzer
hier
eingehen und sagen ja seht ihr die
ukraine haben sich versteckt zwischen
den zivilisten aber natürlich dass das
die realität wo sollen sich die ukraine
verstecken wo sollen sie sich schützen
wenn nicht genau in den häusern die sie
verteidigen ein putin differenziert ja
auch nicht zwischen militärischen zielen
auf der einen seite und zivil auf der
anderen insofern haben sich die ukraine
man sieht dass hier sozusagen im
hauseingang verschanzt und haben
versucht hier widerstand zu leisten sind
aber dann geflüchtet haben sich
zurückgezogen als die russische armee
hier rein gegangen ist zu guter letzt
das meist schlechter netz sehen wir hier
das russische truppen auch im zentrum
der stadt sind das also relativ bekannte
gebäude man sieht also da eine große
halle die von oben mit der ukrainischen
flagge bemalt ist also in gelb und blau
unternehmen auch relativ moderne gebäude
die in letzten jahren erst gebaut wurden
ja eine großstadt 100.000 einwohner die
vorletzte großstadt nehmen dass die fans
die noch von der ukraine gehalten wurde
in der region lohans gestern verloren
gegangen ist zum größten teil verloren
gegangen ist an die russische armee
insofern ja eine hiobsbotschaft für die
ukraine die offenbar nicht weiterhin
nicht die front halten kann in der ost
ukraine und weiter zurückgedrängt wird
in dem fall wir sehen es viel weniger
zerstörung als beispielsweise mario pohl
oder in europäischen oder ein passender
wo man wochen lang darum kämpfte
offenbar hat die ukrainische generalstab
entschieden dass in dem moment wo die
russen an der stadtgrenze sind also die
ersten häuser betreten haben dass sich
die ukrainische armee hier komplett
zurückzieht
allerdings heißt es nicht dass die
ukraine aufgibt sondern die ukraine
versucht den fokus zu verschieben und
die ukraine hat gestern oder vorgestern
das ist nicht ganz klar hochgradig
geheim mit einer entlastung offensive
begonnen wir gucken uns das mal an was
wir eben für bilder hatten wir waren ja
hier aus die wir oder netz das heißt
hier im osten wo die russen weiter
vordringen und offenbar gibt es jetzt
eine entlassung offensive in der region
chancen person das ist eine offensive
die hier vorgeführt wird und dort
versucht einen entlastungsangriff zu
starten also ganz weit weg von der front
wo wir wissen wo die allermeisten
russischen truppen im einsatz sind weil
russland hat auch nicht ewig viele
soldaten sondern muss ihnen seiner
soldaten ich habe schon gesagt gesagt
nach etwa 30.000 mann die gefallen sind
schon konzentrieren auf gewisse gebiete
greift also hier seit wochen nicht mehr
eine dieser region dort versucht die
ukraine jetzt eine gegenoffensive zu
starten und wir sehen hier das 1 ein
strategisch wichtiger fluss der in den
letzten wochen als grenze dort fungiert
hat dass der überquert wurde von
ukrainischen schweren einheiten die
hiermit bmp und anderen schützenpanzern
vorrücken und dass die ukraine hier
versucht in der region ein bisschen vor
in der region person mit bodentruppen
und auch mit schweren gepanzerten
fahrzeugen vorzudringen diese
entlastungsangriff ist es noch nicht
klar wie erfolgreich der ist ob das nur
ein ablenkungsmanöver ist oder ob die
ukraine wirklich hier in der region
person vordringen möchte oder eben ob
man bloß den verein sozusagen ablenken
möchte und ihnen sagen möchte wenn ihr
euch ganz doll auf den osten
konzentriert dann wenn wir euch woanders
eingreifen das ist noch unklar wir sehen
auf jeden fall dass es erstmals seit
seit back iv der ukraine ja die vororte
zurückerobert hat also erstmal seit
erstmals seit tagen eine neue
ukrainische gegenoffensive gibt die
versucht zumindest den russen irgend
etwas entgegenzustellen und auch wieder
von russland besetztes gebiet in in
diesem fall im süden der ukraine dann
auch wieder zurückzuerobern